have you noticed the lack of high school  murder mystery games on your PC if  you're not because the  critically-acclaimed dangan ronpa  trigger happy havoc is making the leap  from portable system to personal  computer the game once exclusive to PS  Vita is coming to pc via steam there's  no specific release date but we do know  what's launching in February you can  pre-order for a limited edition that  includes the game 16 song soundtrack to  spare an audio developers spike chunsoft  opened an english-language Twitter  account last week which seemed to tease  this PC version of the game the Vita  version received an 8 out of 10 from  GameSpot which called it an excellent  adventure with a story that celebrates  the human spirit so consider that a  definite recommendation and for more  news about upcoming steam releases  you're already in the right place